JUST A MOMENT.
STAY WITH US.
>> Vice President Pence: ALL
OF OUR EXPERTS TELL US AND THEY
ADVISED THE PRESIDENT TO AVOID
SOCIAL GATHERINGS OF MORE
THAN 10 PEOPLE.
IF YOU ARE SICK, STAY HOME.
IF THERE IS SOMEONE IN YOUR HOME
HOME, CONTRACTS THE CORONAVIRUS,
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD STAY HOME.
>> Ed: PRESIDENT MIKE
PRINCE
--
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE SAYING
TO STAY HOME.
>> Sandra: IS TIME FOR OUR
HEADLINER THIS MORNING,
KELLYANNE CONWAY COUNSEL TO THE
PRESIDENT.
SHE SITS IN ON THE TASK FORCE
MEETINGS BUT IS NOT ON THE
TASK FORCE.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO KNOW?
>> LET THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE TASK FORCE
HAVE BEEN SAYING.
THESE NEW GUIDELINES FROM THE
CDC WILL ACTUALLY MITIGATE THIS
HEALTH CRISIS FOR MANY AND
LITERALLY SAVE LIVES.
WE CAN ALL DO OUR PART BY GOING
TO CDC.GOV, CORONAVIRUS.GOV.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TWEETED THEM
OUT.
THESE ARE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES
FOR THESE VIRUS.
WE ALSO KNOW ABOUT THE
RESILIENCE AND THE STRENGTH AND
THE FORTITUDE OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE KNOW THAT WE ARE A STRONG
UNIFIED NATION WHO WILL HELP THE
ELDERLY WHO CANNOT GET OUT FOR
MEALS, FOR EXAMPLE.
THE USDA JUST APPROVED THE
DELIVERY OF ABOUT ROUGHLY
1 MILLION MEALS PER WEEK TO
WORLD BASE TO STUDENTS.
I TALKED TO THE SECRETARY AT THE
USDA.
HE IN FACT HAS HIS NEW EMAIL
THAT BILLED THAT THE SENATE WILL
VOTE ON TODAY AT THE HOUSE
PASSED LAST WEEK IT DOES INCLUDE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
NUTRITION ASSISTANCE FOR OUR
VULNERABLE POPULATION, PREGNANT
WOMEN, WOMEN UNDER THE POVERTY
LINE, SENIORS, CHILDREN.
IT INCLUDES BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR VACCINES AND PAID FAMILY
LEAVE.
WE CAN ALL DO OUR BEST TO
MITIGATE THE HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
OF THIS VIRUS.
OUR GOVERNMENT IS WORKING
TOGETHER AND WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO END THE ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION AS WELL.
>> Ed: MITCH McCONNELL A
SHORT TIME AGO SAYING THERE WILL
BE A VOTE LATER TODAY.
WE SHALL SEE.
ON PAID LEAVE AND UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE THAT THE HOUSE IS
ALREADY PASSED.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TALKED ABOUT
DRAMATIC RELIEF TO THE AIRLINE
INDUSTRY AS WELL.
SOMETHING IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
$50 BILLION.
HOW QUICKLY DO YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT ON THE CONGRESS
WORKING TOGETHER CAN ACT ON
AIRLINE RELIEF -- A BIGGER
PACKAGE THAT SECRETARY MNUCHIN
HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT?
HOW DID THAT GO?
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
EARLY LAST WEEK OR SO, THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT
ALSO HAVE THE AIRLINE INDUSTRY
REPRESENTED HERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE EARLY ON.
THE VICE PRESIDENT WENT DOWN TO
MIAMI AND TALKED TO THE
CRUISE LINE REPRESENTATIVES.
WE KEEP BRINGING THESE DIFFERENT
PRIVATE SECTORS HERE ON ON THE
PHONE MORE AND MORE.
THE SOCIAL DISTINCT POLICIES.
THE PRESIDENT IS READY TO ACT.
IT DEPENDS ON CONGRESS.
I KNOW THAT THEY ARE WORKING
TOGETHER VERY WELL.
SECRETARY MNUCHIN WAS IN THE
LEAD.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
BRINGING THESE TO THIS INDUSTRY.
MORE PORTLY, THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHOSE ECONOMIC WHEREWITHAL IS
BEING DISRUPTED THROUGH NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN BECAUSE OF THIS
VIRUS.
SECRETARY OF THE TREASURY
MNUCHIN YESTERDAY BROACHED THE
IDEA OF CHECKS GOING TO
INDIVIDUALS.
A WHOLE BUNCH OF ECONOMIC RELIEF
PACKAGES ARE BEING UNDERTAKEN.
WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE SAY WHOLE
OF GOVERNMENT, WHOLE OF AMERICA
APPROACH THAT THERE ARE MANY
TOOLS AT THE PRESIDENT’S
DISPOSAL.
MANY TOOLS THAT THE PRESIDENT
AND CONGRESS ARE WORKING
TOGETHER.
"WE WILL BE BY MUTUAL CONSENT
CLOSING OUR NORTHERN
BORDER WITH CANADA TO
NON-ESSENTIAL TRAFFIC.
TRADE WILL NOT BE AFFECTED.
DETAILS TO FOLLOW!"
THAT WAS THE PRESIDENT AT ONE
HOUR AGO.
HOW DOES HE BELIEVE THAT WILL
MITIGATE THE SPREAD OF THIS
VIRUS?
>> FOR MANY OF THE SAME REASONS
THE PRESIDENT TOOK EARLY ACTION
TO CLOSE ON THE BORDERS WITH
CHINA.
JUST LAST WEEK WITH EUROPE AND
ADDING TO THAT LIST, MAKING VERY
CLEAR THAT CARGO WOULD NOT BE
AFFECTED AND CONGRESS AND TRADE
WILL NOT BE AFFECTED.
THIS IS NOT PUNITIVE.
THIS IS PROTECTION.
FOR US, THE AMERICANS TO CHANGE
THEIR BEHAVIORS, WE ALSO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE KEEPING
OURSELVES PROTECTED AND HEALTHY
HERE.
THAT’S A MUTUAL AGREEMENT
BETWEEN CANADA AND THE U.S.
THEY REACHED OUT TO
PRIME MINISTER JUSTIN TRUDEAU
ABOUT HIS WIFE WHO HAS BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH COVID-19 OR
UNDERGOING A TEST.
AND SO WE CONTINUE -- WE NEED
AMERICANS TO KNOW THAT WE ARE IN
THIS TOGETHER AND WE CAN ALL DO
OUR PART TO MITIGATE THE DAMAGE
AS WELL.
JUST LISTENING TO THESE
BRIEFINGS.
EVERY CABINET AGENCY HAS A ROLE
TO PLAY.
I THINK FEMA IS A VERY FAMILIAR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACTOR.
AN ORGANIZATION TO MANY
AMERICANS.
THEY USUALLY SEE FEMA GET GET
READY FOR A WEATHER EVENT.
IN THIS CASE, THEY SEE FEMA
BEING PREPARED HERE.
WE WANT AMERICANS TO UNDERSTAND
TO REPLACE OVER A PANIC WITH
PREPAREDNESS.
NO ONE SHOULD OVER PANIC OR
REACTS TO THIS.
>> Ed: THE PRESIDENT JUST
TWEETED OUT THAT HE WILL HAVE A
NEWS CONFERENCE.
IS HE DOING SOMETHING ELSE IS
AFTERNOON?
>> STAY TUNED.
THE TASK FORCE WILL HAVE A
BRIEFING TODAY.
FOR THE LAST FOUR CONSECUTIVE
DAYS, THE PRESIDENT HAS LET OFF
AND HAS BEEN THERE TO TAKE THE
QUESTIONS ALSO.
I THINK TRANSPARENCY HAS BEEN
WONDERFUL FOR THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION.
THE PRESIDENT IS ALSO LOOKING TO
SPEAK SEPARATELY AS HE WISHES.
HE USES HIS SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM ALL DAY LONG.
HE IS VERY ENGAGED AND WANTING
TO SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE PUBLIC.
I WILL END WITH THIS, TOO.
WE ARE VERY HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
THE MAJOR NETWORKS, RADIO HAVE
DEVOTED TIME.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
DOING THAT.
EVERYONE HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS.
THESE ARE WOULD-BE COMPETITORS
AS COLLABORATORS SO THAT WE MAKE
SURE WE ARE GETTING THAT MESSAGE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ALL AT
ONCE.
>> Sandra: BEFORE YOU GO, HAS
THE PRESIDENT BEEN BRIEFED ON
THIS 5.7 MAGNITUDE EARTHQUAKE IN
UTAH?
THE AIRPORT IS SHUTTING DOWN A
GROUND STOP RIGHT NOW.
THE CORONAVIRUS HOTLINE IS DOWN.
THERE ARE CLOSURES AND THEY ARE
ASSESSING THE DAMAGE.
>> HE IS BEING BRIEFED, SANDRA.
I LEARNED ABOUT IT AS I CAME OUT
OF THE SITUATION ROOM.
WE HAVE NO MOBILE DEVICES IN
THERE.
OBVIOUSLY, THE SPACE WE NEED IS
BEING GRIEVED.
WE WILL DO WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
HELP YOU TALK TO THAT PRICES.
EVEN IF YOU’RE HOTLINE IS DOWN
THERE ARE FEDERAL ASSETS IN
PLACE THAT YOU CAN ACCESS.
YOU CAN GO TO THE WEBSITE AND
CALLED THE 188 AND NUMBER THAT
THE FDA SET UP THAT FEMA HAD SET
UP.
THERE ARE OTHER MEANS IF YOU
NEED INFORMATION.